- Well, just when you thought
it couldn't get any dumber
the MyPillow company led by Mike Lindell
has counter-sued Dominion Voting Systems,
seemingly in response to the
Dominion suit against MyPillow
for billions of dollars
related to defamation.
But here, this is especially
crazy because the crux
of the MyPillow lawsuit is that Dominion,
a private company,
violated somehow MyPillow's
First Amendment and 14th Amendment rights
and violated Section 1983.
That's not how any of this works.
Just because a private
company has been contracted
by a government doesn't mean
that that private company
is the government itself,
whether they're operating Twitter
or operating as a company
that helps with voting.
That's not how this works.
That's not how any of this works.
So, apparently we'll see them
in court for a very short time
until this lawsuit is easily dismissed.